In 1846, the Daily News became London's newest
newspaper.
Its editor-in-chief was none other than author
Charles Dickens.
Diamonds are actually unstable at surface
temperature and pressure.
Every diamond above ground is very, very slowly
altering into graphite, another form of pure
carbon.
It is impossible to spell a word only using
the bottom row of a QWERTY keyboard.
Medieval Japanese samurai burned incense in
their helmets so that if they were decapitated
in battle, their head would smell sweet.
The lion costume in the film Wizard of Oz
was made from real lions.
The "S" in Harry S. Truman didn't stand for
anything; Truman had a middle initial but
no middle name.
Owls are not only carnivores but also cannibals,
who may eat other owls of a different species.
Most supermarkets place their bakery areas
near the entrance because studies have shown
that the aroma of fresh-baked goods makes
customers spend more money.
Despite being staples of the Old West landscape,
neither horses nor tumbleweeds are native
to North America.
A baby can cost new parents 750 hours of sleep
in the first year.
The first VCR, developed by the Ampex Corporation
in 1956, weighed nearly 680 kg.
It took another 15 years before a commercially
viable product hit the scene.
Kiribati is the only country that falls in
all four hemispheres.
Only a few species of dinosaurs ate meat,
the majority of dinosaurs were herbivores.
Goldfish can distinguish the music of one
composer from another.
The flashes of colored light you see when
you rub your eyes are called "phosphenes."
To save money when you shop, don't touch anything.
Touching an item makes you more likely to
buy it, and be more willing to pay more for
it.